alors ça me comment s'est passée ta
séance avec julien aujourd'hui julia
pense que je devrais me jeter à l'eau et
avoir des rapports sexuels avec
quelqu'un enfin la partie sur le sexe
c'est moi qui les a ajouté je suis un
mec bizarre
enfin c'est ce que tout le monde dit
parfois je comprends pas ce que les gens
veulent dire quand il parle
les personnes souffrant d'autisme
pleures tu sais les filles ne me
remarque jamais vraiment je suis pas
doué pour reconnaître les signaux elle
n'arrête pas de sourire
tu dois le réduire de 70% cas ici
pourquoi ma liste me dit enlève le bal
est ta dans les fesses j'en sais rien
mais ici sur thalys étude wall fernand
je trouve pas mes pantalons de travail
sam va sortir avec des filles tous les
deux on avait le même âge quand on s'est
rencontrés peut-être qu'il est temps
qu'on relativise un peu tu veux savoir
comment voler une fille alors allume son
gps parce que je t'amène à canon ville
c'est pas un endroit qui existe non je
vais pas faire ça
il existe des stratégies que je pourrais
lui après c'est fini je suis plus un
gamin je peux faire des choses est ce
qu'il existe des stratégies quand on a
le coeur brisé
parfois j'aimerais être normal tu sais
personne normale votre fils est comme
nous tous il ya le même désir d'être
aimé
tu payes dit pourquoi nurit il a droit
afrique
[Applaudissements]
ma famille fraîchit ya des sam par ci et
de l'autisme par là tu devrais prendre
un peu de recul
celui qui a dit l'entraînement rend
parfait était un idiot
les humains ne peuvent pas être parfait
parce que nous ne sommes pas des
machines
la meilleure chose que l'on puisse dire
sur l'entraînement c'est qu'il permet de
s'améliorer
un moment donné j'espère vraiment
vraiment j'arriverai à voir des nichons
[Musique]